Clerk: Welcome to GameYield...
...what would you like
to pre-order today?
Pollychester: Oh...no,
I just wanted to buy...
...the new Phthalamon game.
Clerk: Let me check.
Ah, OK.
Do you want Phthalamon
Polyethylene or Polystyrene?
Pollychester:
What's the difference?
Clerk: Well, if you want to
catch all the Phthalamon,
you have to trade
with a friend...
...or if you're sad and lonely,
you can buy both.
Pollychester: I'll go
with Polystyrene...
...because the one on
the front looks better.
Clerk: Everyone does...
Pollymer: Yes!
Game time!
What are we playing today?
Phthalamon Polystyrene
Edition, eh?
All right!
See you in there!
Gotta plasticize 'em all!
Plastikos: Hello there.
Welcome to the
world of Phthalamon!
People call me the
Phthalamon professor.
This world is inhabited
by Phthalamon.
They come from chemicals
called phthalates, and
they are used to change
the properties of plastics.
People use phthalates for
all sorts of purposes:
they can soften plastic,...
...make it more flexible,...
...make plastic
more transparent,...
...or to increase plastic's...
...durability.
Me?
I study Phthalamon.
Your own Phthalamon
adventure is about to begin.
Here's two Phthalamon.
My assistant,
Pollymer, will help you.
Pollychester: But what
will you be doing?
Plastikos: Don't
worry about that.
Go on!
Pollymer: You heard him,
there's a lot to do.
Pollychester: Hey! Wait!
I knew I should have
picked up the guide...
What are we even looking for?
Phthalamon!
They're used in making
plastics, and can be found
almost everywhere!
You can find them...
...around toys,...
...food packaging,...
...medical bags and tubing,...
...plastic coatings,...
...and even some products that
aren't made of plastic.
Buy an overly
expensive vinyl toy?
Phthalates.
Like that "new car" smell?
Phthalates in the air.
Feel how smooth your
hair is after shampooing?
Phthalates in the shampoo.
Like the feel of that slick,
plastic video game system?
Phthalates.
Wait...what?
Let's see what you got.
Let a Phthalamon out.
Diisononyl: DIISO!
Pollymer: That's Diisononyl
Phthalate!
It's a pretty...
...common plasticizer.
Pollychester: Plasticizer?
Pollymer: Sure, any chemical
that gives plastics that
flexible,...
...smooth quality...
...we like in products
is called a plasticizer.
Pollychester: Aw, it's cute too.
Diisononyl: Iiiiisoooo....
Pollymer: I wouldn't do that...
...he may cause cancer.
The state of California
recognizes diisononyl as
a carcinogen.
Pollychester: Why would the
professor study phthalates
if they are dangerous?!
Pollymer: That's exactly why.
Phthalamon are everywhere,
but we aren't sure how much
they affect us.
Pollymer: Some phthalates may
increase the risk of getting
certain kinds of cancers...
...and others may be endocrine
disruptors.
Pollychester: Is this one of
those educational games that
grandparents
accidentally give to kids?
Pollymer: Your endocrine
system is a complex group of
chemicals in your body...
...turning on and off chemical
reactions that keep things
relatively normal in you.
Things like your growth rate,
blood sugar levels, and
internal temperature are
all regulated with help from
your endocrine system.
the phthalates that
are endocrine disrupters
get in your body...
...and block or imitate
endocrine chemicals.
Pollychester: So how
do we find Phthalamon?
Aren't they in the plastic?
Pollymer: Yeah, but
phthalates don't actually
bind to the plastic.
Plastics are made of an
interlocking web of large
molecules, called polymers.
Trapped inside the polymers
are other chemicals,
like phthalates.
Phthalates are much
smaller chemicals, and
they're just mixed in there.
So, if the plastic is heated,
cut up, or dissolved...
...the polymers loosen, and
out come the phthalates!
Phenol and Petrol:
HAHAHAHAHAHA!!!!!
Pollychester: Who was that?
Phenol: To cover the
world in plastic sheen.
Petrol: To wrap your stuff,
and keep it clean.
Phenol: To create any
shape your hearts desire.
Petrol: To cast old
materials into the fire.
Phenol: Phenol!
Petrol: Petrol!
Phenol: Team Plastics,
truly a sight to behold!
Petrol: Don't mess with
us, we break the mold!
Malleowth: Malleowth!
Dat's bold!
Pollymer: Oh gosh,
not these guys...
What do you want?
Petrol: We know you've
caught rare Phthalamon!
Phenol: They can help
us create more plastics!
Malleowth: So give 'em
up or pay da price!
Pollychester: What the heck?
Petrol: When you lose, we're
taking your Phthalamon.
Pollychester: You don't get it!
We have to study them...
...we can't just keep cranking
out more plastics without
understanding what
effects they have on us.
Malleowth: Boring!
Get 'im!
Phenol: Go, Benzylbutyl!
Benzylbutyl: Benzzzzzzyl!
Petrol: Go, Diethyl!
Diethy: Ethyl!
Pollymer: Hey!
Two on one's not fair!
Malleowth: She
missed da point...
...we're da bad guys!
Pollymer: Watch out...
Benzylbutyl phthalate is
common in soft plastics.
It can be found in
road cones, vinyl toys,
and fake leather.
It’s illegal to use Phtha-
lamon in Europe
Pollychester: What
about the gassy one?
Pollymer: That’s
Diethyl phthalate.
It binds to perfumes.
Odds are, if you smell something
“nice”, diethyl’s there.
There are also concerns about
its effects on our
nervous system.
Send out a Phthalamon!
Pollychester: Right...
Dicotyl...I choose you!
Dicotyl: Cotyl!
Pollymer: Wow!
You're really lucky!
That's Dicotyl Terephthalate!
That Pthalamon uses plant oils
instead of synthetic chemicals.
It's a natural alternative
to other phthalates, and
reasearch suggests they don't
have the same health concerns.
Petrol: Awww, it's cute.
Pollychester: Show 'em, Dicotyl!
Dicotyl: DICOTYL!!!!!
Phenol: No way!
These kids aren't
playing around!
Petrol: Show them
what we've got!
Diethylhexyl: Hexyl...
Go, Diethylhexyl Phthalate!
Pollychester: Woah...
Pollymer: That's a
legendary Phthalamon!
It's effect is seen
in most plastics.
Polyvinyl chloride, or PVC,
is a very common plastic.
If a plastic is PVC,...
...Diethylhexyl was involved.
It's a cheap phthalate to use,
but it also has health concerns.
This one's tough...
Pollychester: Get it, Dicotyl!
Dicotyl: DICOT...yl....
Pollymer: It looks like Dicotyl
Terephthalate may be a powerful
plasticizer, but it's also
expensive to use.
Diethylhexyl: Diethyl...
Pollychester: NOOOO!!!!
Petrol: Ready to give up, twerp?
Pollychester: No way!
Go, Diisononyl!
Diisononyl: DIISO!
Malleowth: It ain't dat tough...
Phenol: It sure isn't.
Diethylhexyl: Hexyl...
Pollychester: This
isn't working either!
Pollymer: Wait!
Look at Diisononyl!
Hexamoll: [ROARS]
Pollymer: The chemical
reaction of hydrogenation
turned Diisononyl into Hexamoll!
And look at its attacks!
The harmful side effects
of Diisononyl are gone!
Adding hydrogen to this
phthalate made it less reactive.
This new phthalate could be
better than Diethylhexyl!
Pollychester: Hexamoll!
Seismic malleability!
Phenol: What?!
Diethylhexyl: Hex!
Petrol: Uh...uh...uh...
Petrol, Phenol, and Malleowth:
Looks like Team Plastic's
melting away!
Hexamoll: [ROARS]
Pollychester: It's
difficult to decide
what to do about phthalates.
The plastics that make things
like medical tubing save
millions of lives.
On the other hand, people who
need constant medical treatment
are at greater
risk of the negative
side effects of phthalates.
they could stay in the plastic,
or they could get out and enter
your body through your blood,...
...eating food,...
...or just breathing.
Pollymer: But with work, we
can make our plastics safer.
If we look for natural
alternatives...
...like Dicotyl.
Dicotyl: Cotyl!...
Polymer: Or we
research methods...
Pollymer: ...for creating
safer phthalates...
...like Hexamoll
Hexamoll: [ROARS]...
Pollymer: ...we can have our
plastics and minimize the risk.
It may take money and time, but
it's better than surrounding
ourselves with products
that have unknown effects.
Pollychester:
There's also ways we can
just avoid using plastics...
...shop with a canvas bag,...
...eat off of glass or ceramic
plates, and use metal flatware.
Pollymer: And keep your plastics
away from heat in microwaves and
dishwashers that
break down plastics...
...and release phthalates
Pollymer: And don't chew
on your plastic stuff...
...it's understandable
for a baby, but come on...
Pollychester: So, we beat the
bad guys and learned a lot.
Did I beat the game?
Pollymer: Oh, you
never "beat" this game.
There's post game
missions, you have to
play the other version...
...there's the tradeable
card game, in about 5 years
they'll do a remake of this
game, you're never done.
This is you now.
Dicotyl: Dicotyl!